31 metropolitan police officers have
been
fined 200 pounds each for breaching
covid regulations
while on duty the officers had their
hair cut
by a professional barber in bethnal
green police station
earlier this month let's cross to the
newsroom
the sky's ender brady and this is one of
those you couldn't make it up stories
ender isn't it what happened
so we understand the metropolitan police
received this
allegation earlier this month it has now
been investigated
and they've put out some information in
the past hour confirming that a group of
31 police officers
all went for a haircut at bethnal green
police station in london's east end
on sunday january the 17th now we
understand that some money was donated
to charity as a result of this activity
however um management at the met have
investigated
those 31 officers will now be fined a
fixed penalty notice of 200 pounds each
and i understand the two officers who
are involved in
organizing the haircut and getting a
professional barber into the police
station
will now be investigated for misconduct
we've got a statement through from the
local
commanding officer and this is detective
chief superintendent marcus barnett
we can take a look at that now and in
this statement he says it is
deeply disappointing and frustrating
that my officers
have fallen short of the expectation to
uphold culvert 19
regulations and he continues by saying
quite rightly the public expect police
to be role models
in following the regulations i hope this
action proves the police are not
immune to enforcement of the rules and
we are prepared as an organization to
take action
if we see officers have behaved
irresponsibly and all of this of course
coming
just about a week after a group of nine
officers from the southeast
basic command unit were seen having
breakfast together inside a cafe
in greenwich and all nine of those
officers also got a 200 pound fixed
penalty notice
ender thank you